all right continuing trying to find
things to bring value to the community
that really is practical and affects
your pockets in your bank account this
is exploded since covid so many people
bought so many pets and now a lot of
them are back to their real day-to-day
Life opening up a market of supply and
demand opportunities for a lot of you
you were insanely passionate about dogs
cats and other animals 20 to 40 to even
fifty dollars a month an hour in big
markets is a real tangible amount of
side cash but on top of it the job
itself leads to an incredible
opportunity for Content creation at
scale so not only you get paid 30 or 40
an hour to pet sit or dog walk but
you're now making content obviously with
permission from the owners and that's
leading to opportunities for more
awareness for you this all can lead to a
meaningful pet caring daycare business
and that's your actual passion side
hustles turn to happy lives pay
attention to this trend